this iconic dish is all about the
details french toast might look super
simple to make but looks can be
deceiving french toast is crispy on the
outside that silky custard on the inside
it's just so indulgent and delicious
what's not to love so over the last
couple of weeks we've eaten a ton of
butter and bread and syrup to find out
what makes the best classic french toast
recipe
[Music]
french toast is only as good as its
bread so that's where we'll start there
are a ton of options out there and we
tested a bunch of them
for french toast we want to use a bread
that's both sturdy on the outside and
spongy and tender on the inside
something like a brioche challah or
white bread
we also tested milk bread hawaiian bread
and sourdough but found they really
altered the flavor profile of the dish
ultimately hollow was our favorite we
don't recommend buying a pre-sliced loaf
because we want our slices to be the
perfect thickness
if they're too thin they'll fall apart
with the weight of the custard but if
they're too thick it'll be difficult to
cook the custard all the way through and
nobody wants raw custard we think about
an inch to an inch and a half is the
perfect thickness now this next part
might seem counter-intuitive but we
don't want to use fresh bread we want it
to be at least a day old using fresh
bread will result in dense and soggy
toast but don't worry if you need french
toast right now and your bread isn't
ready just bake your slices at 200
degrees fahrenheit for 10 minutes to dry
them out and then you'll be ready to
make your custard the custard is really
where the magic happens when it comes to
french toast the perfect custard creates
a crispy exterior with a silky rich
interior if you use too much milk or a
lot of sugar in your custard the egg
won't cook and you'll get wet and soggy
toast so a good rule we follow is that
for about every quarter cup of dairy we
use one large egg for our recipe we'll
be using six large eggs it's important
to thoroughly whisk the eggs so you
don't end up with clumps of egg whites
in your custard that will ruin an
otherwise perfectly golden brown piece
of toast then we'll add our milk heavy
cream brown sugar and salt finally we're
going to add our seasoning seasoning
your custard is crucial now you can
definitely get fancy with it by adding
things like cardamom orange zest nutmeg
cloves ginger lemon zest or even
liqueurs but we found that less is more
when it comes to seasoning so we're just
adding a little cinnamon
and some vanilla paste you can totally
make this with vanilla extract but we
think it's worth the upgrade to use
vanilla bean paste it just packs a
bigger vanilla punch and it's still
cheaper than vanilla beans we'll whisk
all of our custard ingredients together
until it's well combined remember we
don't want any egg clumps
now that our custard's ready let's add
our bread we want to make sure the
custard completely soaks the bread but
we don't want to soak it for so long
that it begins to disintegrate
yeah it's just super gross so we'll soak
the bread until it begins to feel heavy
in our hands and completely saturated
throughout this could mean anywhere from
20 seconds to a minute on each side
now that our bread has taken a little
custard bath it's time to cook we tested
several methods your cast iron has to be
seasoned super well or your bread will
end up sticking to the pan the oven is a
great method for making big batches but
doesn't get the crispy edges we want in
a truly great french toast
so ultimately we love using a non-stick
electric griddle it distributes heat
evenly across its entire surface and
it's also big enough to cook large
batches of toast at a time but if you
don't have a griddle a non-stick pan
works just as well now to get a golden
brown crispy toast it's crucial to
preheat whatever pan you choose by
preheating the pan the custard will
begin to cook immediately if the pans
cold from the start the custard will
spread to form a foot something like
this on the bottom of the toast we
recommend preheating your pan before you
start making your custard once our pan
is hot enough we'll lightly grease it
with a pad of butter
or something a little more than a pat we
like our butter here at tasty once all
of that butter is melted we'll place the
soaked toast on the pan and let it cook
undisturbed until the bottom is golden
brown which takes about two minutes then
we'll flip and repeat on the other side
oh she's pretty just look at how crispy
and golden brown that is make sure to
keep an eye on your heat as you cook if
it's too high the sugar in the custard
will burn before the custard is cooked
through all the way in the middle once
your toast is looking beautiful we'll
remove it from the pan and here's a
little tip wipe your pan between batches
to make sure the butter doesn't continue
to cook and leave burnt patches on the
remaining toast now that we've whipped
up perfect golden brown crispy toast
it's time to serve you can really get
creative with the toppings for this use
whipped cream chocolate syrup
sprinkles bananas you can go wild but we
think that less is more we love to serve
ours with a pot of butter and some maple
syrup did you know that there's a
difference between pure maple syrup and
pancake syrup pancake syrup is actually
made with corn syrup and maple flavoring
it's definitely a more affordable and
shelf-stable alternative but if you can
splurge we love using warm pure maple
syrup drizzle that right over the top of
your toast and if you want to get fancy
with it finish with a little flaky sea
salt the sea salt really complements the
sweetness in the custard and syrup we
like to add a little pop of color so
we'll serve ours with a mix of berries
we're just using our favorites here and
we're done all that's left to do now is
enjoy your work of art with your friends
and your family on a wonderful brunch
afternoon or just indulge by yourself
either way if you loaf this recipe you
can find it and many more on our website
at tasty.com what's that thing that you
put on french toast sorry are you saying
syrup how do you say it bro it's syrup i
think people say it like me
you